alors il n'ya pas il n'y a pas de règle
ça peut durer cette durée 2 heures ça
peut durer toute la journée
on ne sait pas
on sait que c'est très attendu on sait
que les conseils et c'est normal de la
partie si les parties civiles attendent
ce moment avec impatience ils l'ont
demandé
et donc effectivement il va voir un
certain nombre de questions à poser à
john et elle pour notre part on va déjà
assisté à tous et en tant que spectateur
peut-être acteurs on verra si des
questions s'imposent un moment un autre
notamment à grégory gay nous posons des
questions et notamment stéphanie sachant
qu'on a très peu de questions à poser
en réalité aux agents pied à son épouse
s quel genre de question pour l'instant
c'est totalement con financier qu'est ce
que vous vous attendez de cette journée
elle est risquée pour vous rien du tout
les pas risqué pour nous
on n'est pas inquiets de rien quoi qu'il
se passe que johnattan d'aval maintienne
sa version change sa version scénique
quelque chose qui nous inquiète
ni un risque dans le dossier faut bien
comprendre une chose c'est que
l'instruction sert à trouver la vérité
et c'est qu'un procès d'assises partir
constructif que la décision de cette
cour d'assises soit la plus juste
possible
il vaut mieux qu'on soit dans la vérité
donc nous on est inquiet de rien on ne
sait pas ce que la drogue johnatan sais
pas ce que veut dire grégory gay on
n'attend pas forcément la vérité de
johnatan ni forcément grégory y est mais
on ne craint rien ni de lancer de
journée quoi qu'on puisse se passe il
pourrait changer sa version alors c'est
un tout dans ce dossier il ya déjà eu
beaucoup d'évolution tout est toujours
possible
grégory gay pourrait aussi changer la
sienne alors un mètre et steve l'a vu
hier il était relativement serein
normalement angoisses et si je peux
utiliser cette formule parce qu'ils
passent devant les juges d'instruction
parce qu'il sait qu'il est très attendu
par notamment grégory gay qui a été très
incisif et rêve actif on va dire même au
niveau de la presse ces derniers temps
donc effectivement cette confrontation
est angoissante
ça se passera comme en matériellement
les quatre matériellement la défense de
john athènes a demandé quatre
confrontations séparer ce qui est prévu
par le code de procédure pénale c'est un
droit et bien évidemment le juge
d'instruction a fait droit à cette
demande des avocats de la défense de joe
natale techniquement ce sont les partis
qui s'exprime dans quels cas ce que vous
pourrez vous pouvez intervenir vous dans
le cadre prévu par la loi c'est à dire
qu'une fois que le juge d'instruction a
fini de confronter les parties
avocat les conseils de la défense et la
partie civile et